I've never seen anything like the
emotion from any commentator around
those tragedies as I'm watching about a
foreign tragedy I think that's odd this
I think maybe gets to the heart in a
less personal way about what's going on
here largely in terms of our national
conversation so here they are talking
about the how the emotions over the last
month um in Tucker's estimation have
been
disregulated there's also I can't help
but notice that your views reflect mine
I would say pretty much I'm I'm American
I was horrified by what happened on
October 7th I think was pretty strange
um I don't really understand how it
happened but Innocents died and that's
awful and I hated watching that and I
feel so sorry for the Israelis um who
were
killed however there's an emotional
response that is disproportionate I
think on the part of some commentators I
mean our country is being invaded right
now by millions of young men whose
identities we don't know who probably
don't even like America and they're now
living here over 100,000 Americans di a
fenel I've known a couple those are real
tragedies I've never seen anything like
the emotion from any commentator around
those tragedies as I'm watching about a
foreign tragedy I think that's odd okay
first off I have to address one thing up
top which is that this is not purely a
foreign tragedy uh we think that
probably 20 Americans were killed and
that there are probably 12 Americans
that are still hostages right now I
don't I don't see any emotion from them
about that that that may look I will
grant the the longest leash possible
maybe that was a total oversight on
Tucker's part right there maybe I don't
know uh but I want to hit a couple
points here uh you know a few things can
be true at once Tucker is not wrong that
as Americans we should always prioritize
America's interests first before any
Nation when he talks about conservative
commentators I don't think he's talking
about me specifically but do I talk
about this the Border virtually every
day on this show and connect that to the
drug problem and what it's doing to our
in cities and everything else I have no
doubt that Ben Shapiro is doing that as
well and Glenn Beck is doing that as
well and everything else so uh he's so
that's just one little piece here but
Americans ought to be able to be a
pro-america first and and understand
that there are people who slightly emote
differently and prioritize differently
and all of those things and by the way
we have candidates who address these
things a little bit differently right we
have Trump who addresses it in one way
and Des santis who addresses it in one
way and Haley who dresses it in one way
but the point is that we should be able
to walk and chew gum at the same time
right and of course you should be able
to be concerned about our border and
want our border I how many times on this
show have I said that we should be
closing down our border and we should
not be letting any of these people in
and we have to figure out who's here and
we're going to have to get rid of some
of them and all of those things and we
all know I know people who have died of
fentol I know someone who's who's hooked
on fentanyl right now um so everyone is
concerned about these things it is
possible
that the sheer barbarity of the events
and and the videos that we've shown you
here and some of the ones that you've
seen elsewhere or that I don't even want
to show you uh would would jar some
people into being more emotional it is
also possible that Jews in general might
be generally speaking a little more thin
skinned when there's a massive attack
against them because Jews have been
programmed and Holocaust and everything
else across the globe so Jews might be a
little more sensitive to that uh but it
is also true that we should all care
about not only the American citizens
over there but that there is a
civilizational battle happening right
now right what have I been saying for
weeks now if if you think that when
they're done with the Jews over there
they're going to magically be done with
the Jews in London but it's not the Jews
that's the point that they're going to
magically be done with all the Western
values in London and Paris and Belgium
and Montreal and everywhere else well of
course they're not going to be it is
just going to be the beginning so when
when they're going for the Jews now it
is the whites next and I think I have
offered a pretty fair defense of white
people on this show a well-deserved uh
uh defense because of course the Jews
are just the first line in what actually
is going on here so then it hearkens to
the to the question does this mean that
America should get involved militarily
and and send our troops across the
Middle East and everything else no I'm
not for that I'm actually not for that
what I am for is that we can offer a lot
of diplomatic Court we can offer a
certain amount of weapons as needed to
understand to beat an evil terrorist
organization the same way we defeated
Isis and nobody said that we shouldn't
be allowed to we might want to do
something like
that